[Music]
black panther wakanda forever one of the
most anticipated mcu movies lately will
finally be released this year in this
video we provide you with an overview of
all the details that are known so far
about the marvel sequel we wish you lots
of fun with our new original and of
course there is a risk of spoilers
regarding the first part
speaking of which let's first turn our
attention to a brief recap of part one
the story of black panther from 2018
takes place after the events of captain
america civil war and shows the then
prince t'challa returning to wakanda and
being crowned king after the death of
his father however he quickly finds that
he has to face a lot of resentment as a
result of his post especially among the
different political groups in the
country first and foremost he has to
deal with his opponent's killmonger and
claw it later leads to the fateful fight
between killmonger and t'challa during
which the king's old advisor zuri
tragically dies at first glance it
appears that t'challa was killed by
killmonger when he was thrown out into
the warrior faults though he's later
found and nursed back to health by the
jabari t'challa eventually returns and
prevents killmonger's reckless plan to
deliver wakanda's advanced weapons to
all the oppressed blacks across the
world together with his allies t'challa
finally manages to mortally wound his
adversary killmonger in the great mount
thus regaining rule over wakanda so much
for the storyline of the first part now
that you're ready for the sequel let's
talk about the possible plotline of the
second part naturally the tragic death
of t'challa actor chadwick boseman
nearly two years ago is still very much
on our minds aside from the human loss
which left many colleagues and the
entire hollywood community in grief
there was also the question of how to
proceed with a character challa it is
also certain that the role was not
recast which is a good decision that we
can all agree upon also the general
direction that the sequel will take is
pretty clear there will be more focus on
well-known characters and a deeper
insight into wakandan history and
mythology since the exact plot is still
largely unknown there are many rumors
surrounding the mcu film at least one
thing is certain in addition to the new
main character shuri especially the
villain neymar the submariner will
create a stir neymar is the rule of
atlantis and originally the marvel
equivalent of dc's aquaman except he's
evil he's the son of a human and an
atlantean princess so his allegiance is
entirely to the sea kingdom his
abilities are wide-ranging in addition
to classic superpowers like superhuman
speed strength and endurance he can also
fly take the form of amphibians and
control other sea creatures nevertheless
the blue eyed villain also has one
crucial weakness which becomes apparent
when he has been out of the water for a
long time the longer he stays out of it
the weaker his powers become however as
soon as he gets the chance to briefly
dive down again his strength is
immediately restored his second weakness
is rather human because neymar gets
easily angered and upset which is due to
the amount of oxygen in his blood and
last but not least almost every ordinary
human has the chance to defeat neymar
since his body has one crucial weak
point his head is extremely sensitive
exactly why this is the case is not
known for sure but given the name of
superhuman speed you have to be very
lucky to hit this target with the
appearance of neymar of the submariner
it is also clear that the old conflict
between wakanda and atlantis will be one
of the central storylines of the film
the enmity between the two kingdoms is
based on a past attack by atlantis on
wakanda the impact of the invasion on
the land was devastating and marks the
beginning of the hostility between the
two advanced nations meanwhile when the
two eventually have to work together due
to the so-called incursions shuri who
will be the main character in the
upcoming installment decides to secretly
invade atlantis neymar in turn sees this
as a declaration of war which is
precisely why he uses his strongest
weapon thanos in the comics the enmity
between the two nations ends with
t'challa banishing neymar to a parallel
universe on the brink of destruction
which signifies neymar's certain death
this fate is of course impossible on
black panther wakanda forever without
the presence of king t'challa which is
why it's up to shuri and her allies to
decide how to deal with the conflict as
you can see a suspenseful sequel is on
the way which will most definitely have
a lot to offer the characters of shuri
and neymar in particular will be
groundbreaking as this is where the
movie deviates from the original comic
and can set its very own course in any
case we are eagerly awaiting the precise
plot of black panther 2.
let's now move on to the lengthy
production of the mcu blockbuster
already at an early stage the
responsible parties agreed on a sequel
to the successful black panther director
and screenwriter ryan coogler who
directed both films spoke about his
ambitions for the follow-up back in may
2018. in the course of this he also
revealed that he would have a great
interest in his spin-off with female
protagonists as he had clearly preferred
the scenes with the female characters
and the editing of black panther thus
marvel and coogler agreed to work
together on the project again and
shooting was set to begin in early 2020
after delays caused by the pandemic
chadwick boseman unexpectedly passed
away on august 28 2020. neither coogler
nor kevin feige or other marvel
executives knew about the actor serious
illness coogler spent about a year
riding the task trip with t'challa at
the center without suspecting that the
movie would not even be released on this
form the following weeks must have been
extremely challenging for the cast and
crew after all they had to find a
solution for the sequel in a timely
manner in addition to their personal
mourning after much back and forth
disney decided to neither cast the
character with a new actor not let it
live on digitally in any way as a result
of the chaos behind the scenes filming
was finally postponed until the summer
of 2021 due to the omission of the
character t'challa kevin feige confirmed
in january 2021 that they would rather
focus on the other interesting
characters of the first part and explore
the complex subcultures of wakanda only
a few months later the official title of
the sequel was revealed black panther
wakanda forever when filming started in
atlanta on june 29th it was not yet
apparent that another major problem
would soon arise at the end of august
2021 almost exactly one year after
bozeman's death shuri actress leticia
wright sustained an injury during
filming despite the actually only slide
injuries to her shoulder she had to
recover for several months which is why
shooting temporarily came to standstill
again after a truly exhausting and
tragic production the final take was
finally shot on march 24th 2022
next we will have a look at the cast
which is luckily known to a large degree
the main role will be played by leticia
wright with her character shuri also
making a comeback with her are lupita
nyong'o as nakia winston duke as back
will deny guerrera as general okoye
angela bassett as ramonda and danny
zepani as board a tribe elder morgan
freeman will likewise return to play the
role of agent everett ross moreover
marvel fans can look forward to an
appearance by dominic thorne as iron
heart this marks her mcu debut as the
unofficial successor to iron man even
prior to being seen in her own disney
plus series it is still unclear whether
killmonger will make another appearance
after all he did actually die in the
first installment many are sure that he
will return in some form although there
is no official confirmation yet equally
unconfirmed is an appearance by dr doom
who according to some reports will make
a very brief but memorable debut this is
not unlikely after all he's the nemesis
of the fantastic four and has wanted to
take control of wakanda many times in
the past
and there you have it this was our
original for black panther wakanda
forever did you enjoy watching this
video and would you have wanted a
different approach for chadwick
boseman's role as king t'challa feel
free to let us know in the comments we
can hardly wait for the sequel black
panther wakanda forever is scheduled for
release on november 11th
2022 we are very excited to see what
will happen see you next time
[Music]
you